I've been in business for 14 years. We spend tens of millions of dollars per year in paid advertising, and in this video I'm going to share something I've never shared before - which is that I have 12 internal hacks that we use whenever we write any piece of advertising or copy that goes out to sell stuff. And I'm going to give you all of them. So let's start with number one - Headlines Come First for a reason and the reason I have it as the first one is that it is the first and most important so to quote David Oggovy uh once you've written your headline you spent 80 cents of your advertising dollar right and so that means that the vast majority of people will only see the headlines in whatever it is that you make and it almost feels unfair that a headline is just a phrase or one word or one question but it is also the thing that is ultimately going to get the most people to or have the biggest lever on whether your advertisements do well so think about it like this because it's the law of small numbers which is if you go from let's say a 1% click-through rate to a 3% click-through rate you triple the amount of of people who are ultimately going to see everything else that you have and so there's very little things that happen in the rest of the entire funnel that have the ability to triple sometimes you get 20% lift 50% lifts that'd be a monster split test but a banger or killer headline can absolutely outperform the control by two three sometimes 5x right that is why it's so important and it feels unfair because it's so short but the thing is is the best advertisers the more they've been doing it the more they obsess on the hook they obsess on the headline because they know that's where the money's at right like if you have a winning hook for your ad campaigns you keep using it to death and you try and beat it and so here's the here's some of the things that I write down which is curiosity is king different is ideal and sexy works and never run an ad without a headline because the thing is is all ads have headlines there's just bad ones and good ones because if you don't write a headline you do have a headline it's just not very good and so fundamentally the headlines serve to give us a different wrapping paper for the same offers and you want this headline to be so powerful and I like this visual it grabs the reader by the throat right and so bonus points is how can I know that something's going to work ahead of time one of the best ways to test headlines and hooks is to look at your organic content or other people's organic content or other people's ads look at the first 3 seconds visually and verbally what are they saying and what's happening in the background and those are the first places that I'm going to look in order to model what headlines apply to me now the the really sexy hack around this is can I take can I steal like an artist from a different industry can I look at ads that are working well in the travel space and use them in business can I look at ads in the weight loss space and use them in business or whatever space you're in and so some thoughts I have are curiosity quotes questions are there kind of emotional outcomes or experiences that I'm describing one of my favorite headlines of all time is how to yay without boo if you biggest insecurity right i'll say that again how to yay good thing without boo bad thing even if you biggest fear how to speak confidently in front of strangers without ever practicing even if you're deathly afraid of speaking in public fyi there are entire books written on each of these 12 pieces that I'm going to talk about i'm trying to give you the 8020 because at the end of the day when you're writing ads you're not going to read 12 books before you write the ad you're going to have a little mental checklist that you go over and that's the checklist I'm giving you yeah and so each of these bullets are kind of like the best like best converting nuggets that I have on each of these kind of mini topics and so this is like my little cheat sheet so whenever I get stuck or I need a new idea or for a new image or a video or copy this is what I use to kind of remind myself number two say what only you can say so if you've done something remarkable or different you want to say it proof will always outdo promise so the reason at the very beginning of this video I said we spent tens of millions of dollars on ads last year between our portfolio companies so this isn't like we don't have an agency that's actually us spending money in our actual companies um so it's not like me taking credit for all the clients that I have uh like it's not that it's like these are companies that I own that we spent money on to generate revenue right so we risk real money behind these things now if you're the only triple black belt in your local area say so if you're the only person who's helped moms over 35 who are vegan powerlifters say so if you're the only person who like the thing is is that what you want to do is you want to be one of a kind but the beauty is that you get to control what the pond that you're one of a kind is and so the friendly reminder here is that competitors can copy your offer but they cannot copy your proof that has to be earned and so one of the big reasons the big defenses that I believe exists for people who have done stuff which is why you should do stuff is that it doesn't matter how many AI avatars come out the AI avatar can never have done something in the real world they can lie but they can never have done something and so no one can take your story or your experiences away from you and this is one of the things that excites me about the future of AI is that story is still going to be paramount why should I listen to you is still going to be a question at the top of everyone's mind and in a world where trust is going to get diminished very rapidly where we're not going to know what's real and what isn't verification of facts is going to be even more important so say what only you can say number three always call out who you're looking for and bonus points who you're not looking for which is actually even more powerful than the original call out so because it's one thing to say hey you know I'm looking for business owners but if you say hey if you're below $250,000 a year you're below $500,000 you're below a million dollar a year hey this isn't for you go consume my free content it it communicates very strongly where you position yourself in the marketplace and so if you only want to help people who want to lose a lot of weight not a little bit of weight like there's a big advantage you know what's funny i've actually never seen anyone in weight loss do this but just say like "Hey only for people who are trying to look o lose over 30 lbs." Here's the crazy part there's enough people who are trying to lose over 30 lbs that you can say no to the people who have less than 30 lbs to lose here's the other great thing about people who have over 30 lbs to lose is that you might only need a couple hundred customers in order to make your business work and there's like a billion people many billions but maybe only a billion that speak your language doesn't matter point is is that most people are afraid of saying no to customers but when you say no to customers you polarize the customers who are the right customer to move even more towards you what you don't want to be is vanilla if you say "I'm everything to all people i accept all customers." Then it means no one feels pulled to your marketing because they're never going to think "Oh this is for me." That is the result that we want to have happen from our advertising that someone self- selects they raise their hand and be like "Wow I feel like this person's talking to me." And so when you advertise you never advertise to the masses you advertise to one person and so you want to be very clear when you're writing your copy who is that one person i want to identify the reader i want to identify the viewer or the listener right and you want them to think how does he know my secrets well you can only be that specific if you're talking about one person and so as you go through this you can go through different levels of awareness which is like at the top level someone can be completely unaware so you have to hook them with curiosity at a level underneath of that you have to have someone who might be problem aware hey do you get up at night to pee more than two times hey have you ever had someone cancel a contract before it comes due right these are problem aware then you have solution aware which is like have you ever tried to collect using some of these softwares and it hasn't worked the way it was supposed to have you ever tried a supplement and it hasn't gotten the results that you want that's solution aware right underneath of that you have product aware okay have you ever tried this type of creatine versus this type have you ever tried an ad agency before that's done meta ads right these are very very more aware customers and finally the most aware customers are people who already know about you and about your product and then you have to make offers to those people but at all all the way through the stack we want to talk to people as though we know who they are because you probably do and the crazy thing is that customers this is the crazy part about customers we all you want to lean into the fact that everyone is selfish everyone thinks they're the center of their own universe and when you can say something that actually affects many many people but you can say it as though they think that they're alone in the universe when you are specific that is what creates compelling copy specificity and so if I say "Hey are you overweight?" That's that's trit marketing you don't want to use terms like marketing ease like like like um marketing speak marketing lingo right you've read ad copy before and been like "Oh this is ad copy." The way that you get out of that is by taking words that people use and breaking them down into chunks and so by saying "Hey uh instead of saying are you overweight?" It's do you have trouble getting upstairs or going on a a walk for a long period of time without a rash forming between your legs and sweating in places you didn't know you could when you say that that's much more specific and so what we want to think about is what are the moments that someone's going to experience fatness what are the moments someone's going to experience brokenness what are the moments someone's going to experience frustration in their marriage or their friendship or loneliness like we talk about the moments because the moments is what they remember no one remembers the vague words and that's not what gets them to emote or have an emotion and then ultimately lowers the actions threshold so they take the next step and so for example I just had a a cash episode with a gentleman who does bar consulting so he helps bars become more profitable uh like restaurant bars and so when I looked at the copy it looked generic it looked like he was just using marketing lingo rather than saying "Hey when you look behind the bar does it look like a bomb went off?" Right does it look like this is a homeless shelter behind your bar right the thing is is that you're probably going to laugh but the person's probably like "Yeah my bar looks like that it's a mess." Right and the thing is is that that's a moment when they walk in or they look behind the counter and they're like "What happened?" That's the moment we want to pinpoint because they probably had that happen the last seven days and if that pain is is fresh the likelihood that they then take that next action is high so the next one is number four always have a reason why and this is big so I like to use the uh the fraternity party planner uh perspective which is that it doesn't actually matter what reason you use but more so that you have a reason to begin with and so this uh the first point when I started adding this in was um I think I read one of Keini's things ages ago uh where we talked about how when people were cutting other people in line if they had a good reason people were more likely to let them cut in which is basically a persuasion win they said "Hey can I get in line in front of you?" And he's like "Hey I've got this paper I've got to turn in i need to copy it quickly and so people said yes but later they tested it where they just said "Hey I have to get in line because my cat is back home." It has nothing to do with getting in line or needing urgency around the copy they just basically said because insert random reason but having a reason in general for most people makes it better than no reason at all and so the word because is one of the most influential words in the English language use it because it works and so if you are going to use a reason great now you get bonus points for a reason if you can tie it back to urgency or scarcity in some way which I'll talk about those two in more depth later and so when you're giving your reasons why what I encourage you to focus on is giving them the reason why to do the next step and just that right every line of copy sells reading the next line of copy and then those lines of copy sell the click and then the click sells the and then the the landing page that after comes from the click the headline of that page sells the opt-in from the opt-in it sells showing up to the next thing is that we just want to be very clear about our messaging one step at a time because someone can't take nine steps we want to sell one step and be very clear about what we want them to do next right a a confused mind does not buy and a confused mind certainly does not click and so when I say thinking about this as a fraterning party planner is what reasons does a fraterning party planner need in order to plan a party not many at all the bar for having a reason to party is quite low timmy got his wisdom teeth out kegger you know so John broke up with his girlfriend kegger uh it's Tuesday let's drink right and so the idea is that you don't actually have to have a reason that's good in your mind you just need to have a reason in general it could be your birthday it could have been your birthday last month it could be your wife's birthday it could be your dog's birthday right it could be the anniversary of the business there's four dates that you can run for a whole month right it's my dad my dog's birth month this month and for that reason we're running this offer right it does not matter now how do we make it even more compelling and this one's nasty this may be if I had a favorite which is hard to say because it's like picking between your kids um which of course everybody has a favorite child um kidding calm down anyways uh is damaging admissions all right there is probably I mean in my experience nothing more powerful than damaging admissions now what's very interesting about this is they've done research on basically the persuasiveness of somebody who admits their bias upfront so if you say "Hey I make money from these videos in the following ways." People even though they know that you admit you have a bias they are now more likely to believe you because you said you have a bias because you've actually been truthful and so you want to own your flaws and damaging admissions in my opinion are so powerful because they're actually just rooted in truth so you want to always own your flaws of course you have them of course your product isn't perfect say so and what you'll sacrifice in promise you'll gain in trust and trust trumps promise think about the promises that you have to give to a referral very little why because you are borrowing the trust of the introduction of the person so when you get a referral you're like "Yeah uh you helped my friend Sandy so I'll buy." You don't need to promise much at all because they trust you and so I would rather always sacrifice promise to gain trust and so there's a you know the famous Eminem story of uh he figured out when he was rapping that if he owned all of his flaws and he said "I'm short and I'm white and I'm blah blah blah blah." Right he says all these things about them the other person has nothing left to say he pulls all the wind out of their sales he pulls all the punches because he punches himself with that and then they have nothing left and so basically we want to address all of the concerns they have upfront in our damaging admissions and so what happens is the the the linguistic power of this is that you have statement but other statement and the statement that comes after the word but is the part that is the thing you want them to believe and so you say something that is true and believable and damaging to you so that they can believe that thing that comes after but so let me show you how this works so if I said "Hey these markers smell like [__] but they write four times longer than other markers and they don't dry out." You're going to be like "Wow I now believe that more than if I just said these markers last four times longer than other markers before they dry out." If I said they smell terrible and or but they do that it's more persuasive now watch this let's flip it these markers write four times longer than others but they smell like crap what am I emphasizing i'm actually emphasizing the fact that they smell bad not the fact that they write longer and so we use the first part to gain trust for the second half of the statement viagra only works for 4 to 6 hours but you're going to have the time of your life right and so it might raise your your blood pressure but you're going to have an amazing night right our websites are ugly as hell but they convert right our systems are incredibly boring but they work right if I said our systems work but they're incredibly boring I'm going to emphasize on the boring part not on the fact that they work and so by how you organize your language around words like but which are amplifiers it allows you to say damaging admissions in a way that's compelling and so right now what I would like you to do is write down all of the flaws all the things that people complain about the things that you know you could do better and claim them because the thing is that the prospect is already thinking them but if you can claim them instead of them thinking them you acknowledge them gain trust and then when you make your statements they will believe you more so if you want to stand out in a crowded marketplace tell the truth it makes you more authentic and if you can do with humor you get even more bonus points so it's like listen our gym has honestly pretty terrible parking our AC is kind of on and off i don't have the best equipment but our sessions are more fun than everyone else's cuz it's all we've got if I said that you now believe me right the thing is is if you saw an ad that said that you'd be like I kind of believe this guy he's probably not so bad right he's telling the truth and I'll bet you his classes probably are fun now if I just said "We have the most fun sessions." You wouldn't believe me because anyone can say that but what people won't say is the truth so number six show don't tell now this one is one of those ones that you will probably nod your head on and be like "Yes of course show don't tell." But the thing is is when I say show don't tell I'm actually talking more about breaking down the reasoning so kind of like I was alluding to earlier which is instead of saying get more sales describe what the experience of getting more sales means or what that moment would look like like selling somebody that you're running out of order forms because customers are reading their credit cards to you over the phone too fast that is the experience of getting more sales right so you want to note the descriptions of what's happening and the emotions they might experience the overwhelm of having too many phones ring and not enough salespeople that's the experience of getting advertising that works don't just say get more leads describe the experience of what getting more leads means that's what they want to experience they want to see their gym full they want to know what it's like to have a line around the corner they want to know what it's like where they actually have to reorganize their gym so that they can actually make room for more people at the session those are the good problems that we would describe which also yes they're problems but if we describe the future problems they would prefer to have than their current problems those are arguably some of the most compelling things you can include in copy because if you can describe the problems they haven't thought about yet then it's likely that you've experienced them or help other people experience them which then increase the likelihood that they believe it will happen for them and so the big thing here in terms of show don't tell obviously from a creative perspective you want the videos to demonstrate it you want your creative your images to demonstrate it but your actual copy itself you want to use more descriptive language that is specific to the experience they're going to have the moments and I'm going to repeat this theme because it's big what is the moment that someone's going to experience that they got more sales what does that moment feel like what does it look like when what moment will they realize that this has actually occurred show me that sales has occurred describe to me that scenario that is how you write exceptional copy and what's cool about this is if you want to write unique copy the way you describe that moment will always be unique to you compared to other people and so you can always have fresh copy that sounds different and interesting because you're not just going to use the same words everyone uses number seven tie benefits to status whenever possible so a lot of people talk about benefits not features which is true but I like to take this a step further mentally which is a cookbook so fast and easy that all your friends will wonder how you found the time to be fit and cook for your family right that would be okay that's one level right of benefit but the idea is what is the like in that benefit what we tied in is we tied in their friends their friends are going to give them status because of this thing which is just a cookbook right so rather than say "Hey you're going to cook meals fast and easy." Sure that might be an element of it right but so fast that their friends are going to wonder how they're doing it is another level of this and so whenever we can tie status and this is why in the in the lead's book I talk about this on page 140 i talk about the what who when framework this is where this becomes incredibly important and so what we want to do when we're thinking about status and the reason that this framework works so well is that we're thinking about the who right obviously it's them but who is giving them the status because their status within different realms is it their family who's giving them status is it their friends is it their colleagues or co-workers is it their rivals is it their competitors who are they who are they vanquishing and so humans are a competitive species we do desire status because it increases the likelihood that we're able to procreate and create more kids and acquire resources right and so we want to tie all of our benefits to what it's going to do what they ultimately want which is going to be status now what's interesting is that the status that people get is going to be unique to that person within their subgroup so if I'm going to try to describe status to a mother it's going to be probably from kids that excel and other parents wonder how they're parenting not from getting a Lamborghini right now if I'm trying to talk to a hustle bro who's 20 years old then probably talking about a Lamborghini might convert now it might not convert the type of hustle bro that I would be looking for but nonetheless it would convert some person who's interested in that right i'm all about mosy mobiles and having cash cars that you can buy for seven grand and then not have to worry about car payment so you can actually rich in your bank account rather than in other people's eyes but point being if we're writing copy we have to meet them where they're at and so the the wording that we think about this and also just to give you more color on this is that we think past present future so how am I going to create status for them with their spouse them with their wife today and in the future and in the past so now I have multiple different people who are giving and awarding status to this person through the copy we're writing and different time periods so it gives you endless variations and angles to approach the benefits all right and so you want to think the lines so that you can or so that your friend's mouths will drop with envy right that's what we're trying to describe here number eight is that we want to use urgency and scarcity all right now to be clear urgency and scarcity people lock them together but they're actually different things all right so scarcity is a function of quantity urgency is a function of time all right so that means that I have an unlimited amount of widgets that I'm trying to sell but I'm only running my promotion until midnight it's a it's a function of time that's urgency if I only have a hundred widgets or I'm only choosing to sell 100 spots which scarcity you can choose to have then at that point once a 100 spots maybe that takes a year to sell or maybe it takes 5 seconds to sell that line in the sand no matter how many people want to buy it after that point cannot buy it now you can have both but fundamentally all we're trying to do is show that other people want it and that they have to act quickly what we're trying to do is decrease the action threshold threshold so they take action and the key to making urgency and scarcity work is making it legitimate there's actually I don't even know if there's really much more to it than actually having it be legitimate there's there's really not another secret now there's different types of urgency and scarcity which I talk about in the offers books so I have a whole chapter uh in the offers books so page 104 for scarcity and then the next chapter right afterwards I have for urgency which is uh page 112 and so I talk about four different types of urgency and different things that you can do to include scarcity um in your offerings whether it's products or services but no matter what you just needed to be real that's all I can tell you and the part that people struggle with is they're like but what if someone wants to buy after midnight what if someone wants to buy when I already said I have 100 spots it means you say no and you say no so you can maintain the reputation so that the next time you have scarcity guess who the first buyer is going to be the one who wasn't able to buy the last time so you're digging your well before you're thirsty i would always prefer to underell my demand so I always have more later otherwise you're always going to be looking for the next kill the next sale and you're going to be putting the scarcity urgency up but everyone knows it doesn't matter because you're not going to sell out and that's where you start losing power now number nine is implied authority all right now this isn't this is a nasty one in a cool way so this actually goes back to number one so if you're the only double secret black belt in the area say it right if you've transformed over you know a thousand people to black belts say so if you're the only you know if you have a pro alete client and they allow you to say it say it all of these things imply authority and people listen to and trust authority figures more and so that's how we've helped 5,000 gyms or 6,000 gyms over the last seven years and so part of authority is also just longevity if you say we've been in business for 40 years the likelihood that you are a legitimate business is pretty high right that's actually a pretty rare feat so if you've been in business for a while that's a big thing now maybe that you and your co-founders in aggregate have done over 20 years of advertising maybe it's four of you guys have all done five years but it sounds better to say in aggregate we've done over 20 years of advertising right now again the the key here is if you have something as a hook like as seen on Oprah's best boot camps or best boot camp in Vegas or best chiropractor in Vegas or best whatever is this is why these tiny little awards matter so much because you can actually even start a sales conversation with did you find us on the Vegas best boot camps list now you might know that no one even knows that this list exists and that's okay because that list just gives you applied authority when you actually have the conversation with a prospect and so at the end of the day this is where proof does beat promise all right and so we're now getting into the believability of the claim right so this is why it's further down on here because someone has to want the thing that you're offering first once they offer it then all their their warning bells are going to go off like "Why should I believe this person?" And that's where you want to have the proof that yes they can believe you and this is why documenting and substantiating the things that you have done and the people that you have helped ultimately makes you more likely to be persuasive right if you have a thousand people who have you know you have a thousand testimonials versus somebody or a thou imagine you go to a you see you looking between two restaurants on Yelp right one has a fivestar with three reviews that's three there you go three reviews right or you've got 3,000 reviews why not let's just stick with it all right but you've got a 4.6 which one are you going for for sure no question you're going to the one that has 4,000 reviews now it's 4,000 uh with a 4.6 rating rather than a five but that doesn't make sense this one has five this is a 4.6 the proof demonstrates the implied authority that obviously these people have been around they know what they're doing they service a lot of customers it's social proof all right now number 10 always have a PS statement all right now why do we have a PS statement so it's a power sentence which is what I like to think about it all right is that power sentence the the two most red parts of advertising number one the headline number two the PS statement and so if you have the two most red lines in all of your advertising you better be sure you're thinking about what you're writing and at the very least have a PS statement right and so always have them and make sure that they're strong and so I have a number of different strategies that I use for PS statements and I'll tell you probably my top three all right so number one in emails I prefer to have some sort of sign off that gets people jazzed they're very excited to have I want to reward them for having read my email so this is where I put jokes in this is where I put fun stuff that's light so that every once in a while when I do want to put a call to action I make this PS a call to action that's strong because I know everyone's going to read it and click it because I've train them to click that link all right now in an advertising setting that PS statement is either going to be a disclaimer of who this is not for which often works really really well hey by the way if you're just getting started this isn't for you this is only for people doing X Y and Z click here that's very strong as a PS statement another PS statement that works very well is just recapping everything in one sentence we've helped a thousand people we're good at making black belts if you're serious about black belts click here boom right and so it's like hey if you did if you just read to the bottom and skip to the bottom like I do this is the main this is the main nuggets right your main points of persuasion all in one place now you can also piggyback on this with a PPS statement and have two PS statements because guess what the only thing that's read uh less than or sorry the only thing that's read more than the normal copy but less than the headline and the PS is the PPS that's the third most read statement in copy so I would also include something there too if you need it now number 11 this one's going to be this one this is like it's amazing how effective this is and also how simple it is and the only thing simpler is to not do it so you have to have clear CTA so calls to action if you do not tell someone exactly what to do next you decrease the likelihood that they do it so you want it to be stupid simple not you know what to do you know you know you have to they don't know right and so if you want X click the button and on the next page fill your information then select a convenient time for you to come in so that you won't miss right we want to be very clear about what they have to do and what's going to happen next right they're not going to guess but here's a really really cool sub point about this if you tell someone to take an option or take a step and then you tell them what's going to happen next and then what you said is going to happen happens you increase your sad do correspondence meaning you gain influence over them because what you said after they followed your instruction came true it's the reason Martha Stewart was such a powerful influencer compared to other people she literally gave people recipes to follow and she said "If you want to bake a cake here's the 18 steps for baking a cake." And when you follow these 18 steps you get a cake and then when you get a cake and the cake the cake tastes good and then you tied to status because other people say "This cake is amazing and your family loves you for baking this cake." Guess what happens she gains influence over you because the next time she gives you instructions you are more likely to follow them and so we can embed this within the process of persuasion so we want to basically make promises keep promises make promises keep promises make promises keep promises over and over and over again where they actually take action and that's the key part is that they have to take action on something you said and what you have to say will happen happens that's what makes it it's not just saying "Oh open loop oh just make promises." They have to take action and then your promise gets fulfilled based on their action so outline step one two three and outline what's going to happen next because when it does they'll believe you the next time you tell them to do something and like I believe in this so much the reason I called my whole company acquisition.com was so that the name of my company was the call to action so if someone's like "Hey how do I find out more about acquisition.com?" I had someone show up in my building and say "Hey how do I apply to acquisition.com?" And I was like number 12 and this is a this is a this is so good this is so good i mean all of these are good this is why I use these like I've really tried to 8020 this for you guys third grade reading level most copy doesn't convert because people have to pause to understand it and the moment they pause they stop because it takes more horsepower than they're willing to dedicate to it so we have to assume that the prospect is in a rush doesn't care about what you have has below a third grade reading level and is distracted and that's the person we have to grab by the throat and bring into our world this is the $100 million scaling road map and what we did was we broke down the 10 stages of scaling and so if you're advertising whether that be in emails for outreach or writing phone scripts or video sales letters or web pages or making content all of these things are messaging that include copy to get people to do stuff and so what we did was we broke down all the different stages of scaling into these 10 steps where you get stuck and how to break through and it's all absolutely free and so if you're a business owner you're not sure where you're at enter your business information it's acquisition.com/roadmap and then on the thank you page if you'd like us to help you with your marketing if you'd like us to help you scale then I'd love to have you come out to one of our workshops we run them monthly here at our headquarters in Vegas so on the thank you page you can book a call but otherwise this is absolutely free you don't need to attend a call or anything like that to get this it's my gift to you so go acquisition.com/roadmap and enjoy the rest of the video sentences that are too complex or use too big of words you're not writing a college paper right you're writing an ad that has milliseconds to catch someone's attention so make the process as frictionless as possible so if you want to make easy copy you want to make light copy the way that you do that is you look at everything that makes copy hard to understand you're writing hard to understand and remove it so great copy the words fade into the background no one's actually thinking about the words they're just understanding what it says and then ultimately being more likely to be persuaded by it so if I have something that's written at ninth grade reading level but or third grade reading level so many people cannot rate at a n read at a nth grade reading level many people can read but they can't read at that level and so if we want to automatically disqualify twothirds of the people who read the copy keep it at nth grade but if you want everyone who can read to read then keep it at third grade look at the most popular books in America they are purposely written because the authors know what they're doing at a level that most people can understand so fancy equals friction simple equals sales i put every ad that I write through free reading level tool and I continue to edit the copy as if it is third grade reading level now I'll give you a couple quick tips on this all right so number one is you want short sentences small words big promises right big proof you want few adverbs and better verbs meaning instead of he quickly ran say he sprinted and so we want word concision we want to have as few words as possible to communicate the point but we want to keep the words themselves as simple as possible now if you're like wait a second sprinting versus running fast sprinting is a more advanced word and this is why writing copy is difficult we have to think is there another word that people also understand that I don't have to use two words and I can use one now at the highest levels I will never prioritize concision over simplicity so simplicity trumps concision meaning fewer words concision itself is like a nth grade word all right um which is using fewer words to say the same thing as many words but you probably understood it better that's what's crazy is this stuff actually works all right and so these are 12 but you know I do like overd delivering so I'm going to give you one more bonus lucky number 13 all right so instead of 13 because that might be uh that might be unlucky so we'll put bonus here i don't believe in superstition but let's just roll with it is whenever possible use humor all right because uh if you look at the Old Spice ad the highest converting ad of all time to my knowledge um in terms of it took something was a not a market leader and make it the made it the the market share uh you know dominator is it was funny right and the thing is is that if you can entertain and educate at the same time you win right because entertainment makes something significantly broader education is what's going to change someone's behavior and so we want our ads to both entertain and educate entertainment to go broad education to go deep the education changes the behavior meaning that they take the click that means that they do what you want them to do this is why now if I had to pick one thing to cut out it would be humor all right because the you can make ads that convert with the other 12 but if you want the extra sauce right tickets to that thing you've always wanted to go to right if you want that extra sizzle then you can add humor in the difficulty is how do you make something funny for everyone and this is where testing is so important right if you look at how comedians I'm a big study of comedy because I really enjoy it um how come comedians make their whole specials is that they will go to many many clubs test new material and they might find when they do a 60-minute set that there's only eight minutes that people really liked they then frontload the first eight minutes their next set and then they have 52 minutes of other stuff and they find two more minutes that people like and they put it there at the front for the next one now they've got 10 minutes and that's how they build their sets until the whole 60 minutes is hilarious because they've tested it in North Carolina and New York and Mexico and internationally and so they've got something that just converts and by converts it means it gets people to do what they want them to do which in the context of comedy is laughing right and so if we can make something that's both funny and educational ultimately we win and if you like this then I have 13 years of business insights that I've learned uh and I think you'll absolutely love that video and